Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to the "Outlast: Whistleblower" DLC!
Now, Outlast was one of my favorite games from recent years...
...and the Whistleblower DLC should prove to be a very good extension on what was already a good formula.
Outlast was great! Obviously, it's at the top of my list of great horror games and one of my favorite playthroughs, but...
...I'm really hoping that the Whistleblower DLC adds something really cool.
What is going on now?
I'm waking up in a bit of a fog...
...oh, hello...
...you here to help me?!
Are you here to hurt me?
...Okay.
Oh, I'm dead. Oh, I'm not dead. Am I dead?
What are you doing to me...?
Why do you need radiation suits to help me?!
(Andrew) Open those eyes. You don't have to wake up, but open your eyes.
(Mark) OKAY THEY'RE OPEN
They're about as op... OW.
(Andrew) What's the matter? Did somebody hit you?
(Mark) ...huh?!
(Andrew) Here. Let me help.
(Mark) ...dickbag! EW! AHH!
NOOOOO!
Stop that!
(Technician) Andrew?
(Mark) U-hgh!
(Technician) You're getting these alerts?
(Andrew) Kinda busy here.
(Mark) Really?!
(Technician) It sounds like real trouble. At the Engine. They said Hope made a lateral ascension.
(Mark) Oh.
(Andrew) Billy Hope? Shit. And they're not happy about it?
(Mark) Huh?
(Technician) No.
(Andrew) Shit. Shit, shit, shit. Come on.
(Mark) I'm still upset about the fact that you gave me a Wet Willie!
Or a Wet Wallie, because you literally just used your tongue and didn't lick your finger...
...what's going on here?
Oh, I can move!
Ooooohh.
"2 hours earlier."
So does this take place during the course of two hours?
Is that what you're trying to tell me here?
"You don't know me. Have to make this quick. They might be monitoring."
"I did 2 weeks of software consult at MURKOFF Psychiatric Systems' facilities in Mount Massive."
"All sorts of NDA's I'm very much breaking right now..."
That is the letter from the first part of the game, that the reporter Miles Upshur...
...or Mike Upaar...
...got and I'm the guy that is actually telling the story about what is going on at Mount Massive asylum.
Just to catch you guys up on what's actually happening.
And I'm willing to bet that this isn't going to go too well for this guy.
He's gonna get to finish this e-mail and he's gonna get a Wet Wallie in his... back side of his ear.
Ogh.
One of the other things that needs to be said...
Oh, send.
Send that bad boy!
(Security) Who's in here?
(Mark) NO ONE'S IN HERE!
(Security) What are you doing?
(Mark) NOT DOING ANYTHING!
Playing games, watching porn...
...you don't need to be worried about anything.
Hello!
Hey!
(Mark) Park?
They've paged for you three times already, there's something urgent at the engine.
(Mark) Oh, okay. Oh, okay.
Yeah, because Billy Hope is about to...
(Security) What were you doing in there anyway?
I thought you were just a software guy.
(P. A.) Waylon Park, employee one four six six...
(Mark) Yeah, there was, uuuh... software in there!
I'm just a weirdo I.T. guy, don't mind me.
(P. A.) ...report to Morphogenic Engine Monitoring immediately.
...are you the guy that licked my ear?
(scientist 1) ...but those are precursors to precursors.
(Mark) Yeah.
(scientist 1) I'm worried about losing antiapoptotics.
(Mark) Really?
(scientist 2) One ninety isn't bad. The doctor was predicting assembly by one fifty.
(Mark) This is an interesting conversation.
(Scientist 1) We're not being given enough information to trust Wernicke's predictions.
(Mark) Okay.
(Scientist 2) He's been right so far.
(Mark) Maybe.
(Scientist 1) I just want to know we're inventing something other than shiny new cancers."
(Mark) Okay. Cool!
You're inventing a diabolical demon...
(P. A.) ...stress response is going to affect the capillaries.
...that's gonna rip apart every single person in here.
(agent) Why weren't you answering the page?
(Mark) UUUH PORN
(agent) I'll tell them you're incoming.
(Mark) Thank you, sir.
How about you?
Am I not supposed to go that way?
All right.
This is back towards the end of the first game!
Oh, by the way, if you haven't seen the first part...
...uh...
...if you haven't seen Outlast in the beginning, it's one of my best playthroughs...
...and I love it to death.
You can find the link in the description below to get the whole story.
(guard) Christ, Waylon, hurry up, they're waiting on you.
(Mark) Thank you.
Thank you, sir. Sorry to keep them waiting.
(Mark) Doing some urgent business that you need not be afrai- wait a minute
- Ah, Park. You're cutting it close.
Next patient's incoming and Arterial Spin's still dark.
(Mark) Cool!
- We need you at the front terminal.
(Mark) Gotcha.
(Steve) They got Gluskin out of his cell.
(Mark) Yeah.
(Steve) Page him again. We need this Park guy in here now.
(Mark) I am here!
(Steve) Tell him he's got fifteen seconds to keep his job. Christ...
(Mark) I'm right here! Jeez... Oh! I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it.
(Steve) Park. Finally.
(Mark) Yeah!
(Steve) Where have you been? The Functional Imaging interface isn't talking to the ASL."
(Mark) I dunno.
(Steve) We got a patient thirty seconds out and we're blind inside his head.
(Mark) Okay. You are definitely the guy who licked my ear.
(Steve) No. I don't need another performance evaluation.
(Mark) Yeah.
(Steve) Mr. Park here is going to have us up and running before we even know it. Right, Mr. Park?
(Mark) Right, boss!
You got it.
I'm here to help.
Not to make everything go wonky crazy.
Psycho bonkers.
Ogh.
For some reason I'm reminded of Half-Life... uh... the Half-Life opening.
(technician) Uh, Steve? fMRI is still dark.
(Mark) It's a functional MRI, by the way.
(Steve) You're doubting our friend Mr. Waylon Park.
Which I consider more than unkind to his programming skill and considerable dedication to the Murkoff corporation.
(Mark) Yeah! This guy's on my side.
(Steve) F*ck me They're bringing him in.
(Mark) He likes me a little too much, if you know what I mean.
Oh, is that the guy?
(patient) No! No! Not again!
(Mark) Is that Billy Hope?
(patient) No! No! Jack-booted fucks, I know what you've been doing to me.
I know what you've been...
Help! Help me! Help me, they're gonna rape me! Rape! RAPE!
(Mark) Euuuugh.
This is going off to a great start, I can...
OH HI!
(patient) Don't let them do this!
(Mark) Hey, handsome, how ya doing?
(patient) I know you can stop this!
(Mark) ...I didn't...
(patient) You have to help me! You have to!
(agent) Hey! Calm yourself. This is a high security...
(Steve) It's alright, agent.
(Mark) WHAT DID I DO?!
(Steve) Mr. Park was just surprised.
(Mark) Yeah!
(Steve) I'm sure he's still calm and eager to finish his work.
(Mark) Calm and eager for you to lick my ear.
Thank you, friend.
(Steve) Quickly, Mr. Park. A head will need to roll if perfusion monitoring is not active when they put him in the engine.
(Mark) Cool.
(Steve) Five seconds.
(Mark) Alright.
(Syeve) Four. Three...
(Mark) OH HI.
You are Billy Hope, aren't you?
I remember that setup you got going on there.
This is gonna go good.
Eugh!
Oh, that poor... oh.
(Steve) You're finished, Mr. Waylon Park.
You may leave. Don't expect anything but honesty in my review of your performance.
(Mark) Thank you.
I know you'll be nothing but kind to me.
Y'all are really weird.
What happens if I stay?!
(Steve) Thank you and goodbye.
(Mark) Uh... I'm just gonna hang around for a little bit and watch all of your cool things going on here.
'He had five kinds of cancer...'
I... there's so much talking going on that I can't see what's going on in the dialog down below.
Uhhhh... Okay. I'm outta here.
'Childhood sexual reptile imagery'...?
What the hell is that?!
Someone draw some f... no, nuh... gah...
What is that?! What in the world are you talking about in there?
You are very weird.
And things are about to go very, VERY wrong.
And I just called a reporter over riiiiight when things are about to go to hell.
Good.
Can I go back to my little desk inside of a dark room...
...where I can just send e-mails to random strangers?
... ...from Close Encounters
Okay.
So, uh...
Oh, I am supposed to go back in here.
Okay. You got it.
Just go back...
(Jeremy Blaire) Somebody's been telling stories outside of class.
(Mark)MO-AGH!
Sorry!
(agent) Hands where I can see them!
(Mark) They are right here!
Hi, friend! Thank you.
(Blaire) Mr. Waylon Park. Consulting contract 8208.
Software engineer with a level 3 security clearance.
(Mark) Yeah.
(Blaire) Graduated cum laude from Berkley...
(Mark) That's me.
(Blaire) ...but still somehow not smart enough to realize that the last thing a fly ought to do in a spider's web is wiggle.
(Mark) EUGH!!
Cool.
(Blaire) Somehow dumb enough to think...
...that a borrowed laptop, an onion router, and a firewall patch...
...would be enough to fool the world's leading supplier of biometric security.
(Mark) Heeeeey, what's your problem, man?
(Blaire) Stupid, Mr. Park.
(Mark) Ooooh no. Yes, so stupid.
(Blaire) In fact, that was... crazy.
(Mark) Yeagh.
(Blaire)I'm afraid we're going to have to have you committed.
(Mark) Oh no ho ho ho.
(Blaire)Mr. Park, will you willingly submit to forced confinement?
(Mark) Heugh heugh heugh.
(Blaire) Did you hear that, agent?
(Mark) Uh...
(Agent) He said yes, Mr. Blaire.
(Mark) Oooh okay.
(Blaire) Oh, and... did I just hear Mr. Waylon Park volunteer for the Morphogenic Engine Program?
(Mark) Yes.
(Agent) That's what I heard, Mr. Blaire.
(Mark) What!?
(Blaire) That was brave, indeed, Waylon.
The Murkoff Corporation and the onward march of science both appreciate your bravery and sacrifice.
Maybe you could administer Mr. Park here a light anesthetic...
(Mark) Oh, I wonder what this is gonna be...Yup! That's what I thought.
Oh, jeez! Was that necessary?!
Okay! Alright! Now we're actually into it!
That was one Hell of an opening, you gotta admit.
Holy Hell! Jeez, man. You light up on me. I just sent one email.
Oh, now I'm here! I thought that was at the end of the game. Was th---Oh.
[screaming]
Okay. That was burned into my brain. That's good.
If I remember, The Morphogenic Engine is like a series of images that instills...
...it causes brain changes that---oh hi.
Shh. Okay. Sorry.
It causes brain changes that allows the person to tap into the psychotic world.
(patient) You hear that, don't you? Do you hear it? Oh... Ah...
(Mark) Or the psychic....HI, BILLY.
Bye, Billy.
Okay
Think it´s my... Oh I got a camcorder ! I got a camcorder!!
Just like in the first one I got a camcorder and I don´t think I wanna see this...
Oh thats gooood
That´s so good for me...
Ohh good ...
One of the great things..
Oh that is intestines on the wall...
how delightful
One of the great things about the first game is that it was so well made
There was a lot of intricate stuff happening both in the animation and it falls ..
Oh Hi...
(variant) Wall flower. Pretty flower. F*cking...
I'll open you up. Open you up and show you.
Make you purr. You wait right there.
I don´t think I should wait right there !!
What? Huh....
I´m gonna go...
I´m gonna go !
I´m gonna go !!
I´M GONNA GO!
Bye! Thank you for letting me out I´m just going on my way now
and you can F off forever and ever and ever...
AND EVER AND EVER AND EVER!
Okay, freaking out in the bathroom that´s a good sign
Anything in here? Anything in here I should know about?
Wait! No whoop...
Forgot how to play ...
It´s been a while since I played the original
and now I gotta play
Ugh.
Oh, batteries!
I need the batteries so I can get the light
the nitro... night vision light
Oh, HI!
That's...
That's not- Hi, I'm not looking at you
Please.
Stop staring at me.
I know you're still staring-Okay, you're
still staring at me!
I'm so sorry everybody.
Just another Morphogenic Engine patient coming along
Oh, God!
(patient) You.
(Mark) Okay!
(patient) No Observers. Come in.
(Mark) What?!
Come-ah?!
Ah!....Uh!
I think....I-uh....
I think I'll pass on this one!
Just go on my... go on my merr-OH HI!
OKAY!! HI, BILLY HOPE!
GO AWAY, PLEASE!
AHH, he's still killing me!
AHH, no don't die!
Billy, please!
AGH!
WHA-what was I supposed to do!
Billy Hope was about to jibble my gibblets!
...dibble my giblets?
Billy Hope was gonna-bah!
Where was I supposed to GO!
He went inside my chest and burst out like an apricot.
Apricot?
[mouths] What?
All right, I'm on my way.
I think I need to pick up that battery again.
Probably.
Oh. No, I got it,
Thankfully it's nice enough for me to not- oh.
I don't need to see that again.
Oh, GOOD!
I'll hide in HERE from Billy!!
This is a GOOD room.
This is a GOOD.
There's a lot of cameras in here for a high-security place
Don't ya think?
That is quite odd and that is quite spectacular how that exploded like that.
AGH! Go this way.
Billy gone?
Good, I think Billy's gone.
Hey, buddy.
Coast is clear you can come out now.
Totally fine, bro.
Oh, whoa!
Jeez- Ey!
That guy's naked!
Come back here!
Have you guys watched- Cry made a really good abridged version of- uh, okay?
Cryaotic made a really good abridged Outast video.
OH, HI!!
(patient) Our peeping Tom, come to join out therapy session.
(Mark) Yeah!
(patient) Here, take the blade.
(Mark) I'd rather not.
(patient) Dig around in our friend here, get a little red on your hands
It's always healthy to express yourself.
(Mark) Right!
(patient) You keep it bottled up too long and you might do something you regret
(Mark) O.K.! COOL!
(patient) No?
(Mark) Umm...
(patient) You're one of those?
(Mark) Oh, yeah!
(patient) Too good for the likes of us?
(Mark) Nnno nno nno!
(patient) Think you're different. Something special.
(Mark) No!
(patient) There are no observers here.
(Mark) 'Kay. I'll uh-
(patient) Now. Get the f*ck out of here before I change my mind.
(Mark) Cool. Cool
Thank you.
Thank you, sir, with your lovely arms.
Looking good. Have you been lifting weights?
Look like you have
I'll just get out of here.
God!
This is like the freakiest intro to a game I've ever pla-
oh HI! Are you there?!
You are there.
AHHH-ffffffffffuuuu
(patient) The f*ck are you trying to go?
(Mark) Agh! What're you doing?! NONONONONO!
(patient) Come back here!
(Mark) Ahh, get outta here.
I didn't think you were actually gonna do anything. JESUS!
God!
Things went to sh*t here really quickly didn't they?
How do I go?
What do I do? What do I do?
Oh, I see. Okay.
Well.
Something fun is happening over there, but I think I'd rather go this way-
Don't mind me, I'm just gonna go up here into the vents and never see your sorry asses ever again.
I have totally forgotten how to play
Good, God!
(guard)... bad idea. we get out of here through reception and let Murk Tactical clean it up.
(Mark) Yeah!
(doctor) If they get out here in time.
(doctor) We need help now!
(Mark) yeaah.
(doctor) If we get them on the radio the National Guard could be here within...
(guard) We don't even know if the radio works
(Mark) Yeah.
(doctor) It's a short wave. If the prison's got electricity they've got signal. And the lights are on.
(guard) Murkoff has it under control.
(Mark) ah-ehhhhh! Ba-ba...
(doctor) Yeah, I noticed. We need to get to that radio.
(guard) Outside help doesn't come without outside attention.
You want to take responsibility for every legally shaky thing you did on the Murkoff company payroll?
(Mark) Uh-huh.
(guard) I know I don't.
(Mark) Rather that than be dead!
(doctor) It's too late to worry about that. This just has to stop.
(Mark) Yeah!
(guard) You're scared. You're not thinking straight.
Let me make something clear.
(Mark) oh-kay~
(guard) You try to radio outside for help,...
(Mark) Oh-kay.
(guard) ... I'm gonna give you a whole new something to be scared of.
(doctor) Are you threatening me?
(guard) Yes.
(Mark) Well then!
Now that we've made that clear and now we understand each other, now we can go into hell in a whole new meaning.
FRIENDS FOR- oh hi.
No, thank you.
Could you stop,...
Could you stop with that...
What? You don't like me filming you, brah?
I'll film you all I want.
Yeah, you better be scared of me!
Better not get up.
That's right! Stay in your ball.
Uh..
[grunts] gotta push this out of the way.
OH, HI!
HI, FRIEND!
Came to help me!!?
Help!
Ya' came to help!?
Is that what you came to do?
Thank you! Thank you, friend.
Good, God!
Oh, man!
I really like this game.
One of the reasons I liked Outlast, the-
[noise/ groan]
Nevermind, I didn't like it at all.
Never liked anything about it. It was actually a crap game.
That- it was really bad.
Isn't this where I started?!
Why am I here?
Why did I need to come back all the way to here-oh, hi...
Yeah, that's definitely where I was before.
I went through that hole in the wall there.
Oh-kay. I gotta- Okay.
I gotta unlock this.
Anyways, one of the things that I really liked about Outlast was how committed they were to the theme.
They pulled no punches on everything- Just look at that; It's horrifying!
It's got a mixture of gore, like the old Splatterhouse horror movies of yonder year.
Like, enormous amounts of gore and also at the same time a creep factor that, God, you don't get on a lot of games
Really well done.
(doctor) I was... I'm a patient like you.
I stole these clothes from a... dead body I found.
(Mark) Okay!
(doctor) You gotta let me out of here, please. Just push the button; open the door. We can get out of here together.
(Mark) Uh... well I don't seem to have any other choice. And you sure seem trustworthy with your blood on you.
I mean that's a good looks for you. Is that the new fall fashion?
Boop!
Oh, good.
Not me, though. Not me, though.
I'm your friend.
...oh-kay...
Have a nice day!
'kay. Ugh.
No, thank you!
That's Billy! That's Billy Hope!
I don't even need to look to know that's Billy
AHHHH!
no!
oooh-kay...
Billy?
-Another one's coming!
(Mark) Yeah, sorry.
I'm crazy! Psycho!
You better stay back!
I'm a loose canon. You'll never know what I'm gonna do next!
I might just do something you will regret.
Well, this looks final.
I think I'll just wander outside.
Did those guys actually make it outside or are they just kidding themselves?
Maybe they fell here and DIED instantaneously.
Oh look! the first document I found.
"Ms. Grant,
you may recieve requests for information form a Mrs. Lisa Park, of Leadville, Co."
"In the coming weeks concerning the resignation and hospitalization oh her husband, Waylon."
...My goodness I cannot talk...
"If so, please forward them to my personal attention.
Waylon Park resigned due to previously undiagnosed mental illness."
"I personally visited Mrs. Lisa Park and her sons and broke the news to them, with the 'silver lining' that"
"Murkoff Psychiatric would be graciously providing treatment."
"Mrs. Park had some less than charitable things to say about myself and the Murkoff corporation."
"I assured her that with her power of attorney she could fight the doctors' diagnosis of her husband's illness."
"However, it it were discovered that he resigned under false pretenses, his insurance would be cancelled and the family"
"would be saddled with not insignificant health care debts."
"Hopefully she understood."
"But if she insists on making a nuisance of herself, or tries to get around me, please let me know."
"This is one I want to take care of personally.
Yours, Jeremy Blaire"
Why do I have a reporter's notebook?
I'm not a reporter, I'm just a tech guy.
I'm an IT man.
All I do is play around with files. And hardware and software.
And make people's head go BOOM in the night.
-[moans]
(Mark) What? What?!
... that got quiet, QUICK!
Why?
And why can't I jump up that; It very much seems that I need to go up here.
this seem-
-[screaming]
(Mark) 'kay.
This is worse than the music!
Turn on the freakin' ambiance!
So I know something's not about to jump out at me
I hear a groaning.
Uh. Dude?
-[groan then yelling]
(Mark) You all right in there? You having trouble?
Bite down on something hard and push!
-[more groaning]
(Mark) You got it.
-[growl/ groan]
(Mark) I believe in you.
Show that turd who's boss.
Be on my way now.
I guess I can go this way? Maybe?
No!
There's gotta be a way I can do something up there. I've gotta get up there. I've gotta be able to push something.
Can I push this?
There's gotta be, like, another thing that I can push up.
'Cause, I mean, this very obviously seems like someplace I can climb up!
But it won't LET ME!
IT WON'T LET ME!
C'mon, c'mon. C'mon, get down with your bad self by getting up there.
Oh, maybe I just- Oh!
I'm an idiot!
I'm a freakin' idiot. I apologize everybody.
I'm so terribly stupid. I'm so terribly stupid.
I'm so terribly dumb.
My brain just doesn't cooperate.
Morphogenic engine making my-
-[screams of pain/ drilling sounds]
(Mark) Oh-kay... cool beans.
I like the Scream of the Damned feel.
Dead doctors lying everywhere. Picture that priest guy...
This is good. This is good.
Can I climb through there?
Do I want to climb through here?
Why are there so many pictures of strange things?
Replace my battery.
Don't see anything I need in here.
Maybe, maybe not.
Maybe, baby!
Maybe in here!
No, it was just a door back to where I was.
Okay, there was no point coming that way
Okay!
Time to parkour my way out to victory!
Hello dead- oh...
Hello dead- oh... HI!
Who's that?!
Did you just pull the head off of someone?!
What are you doing over there?
-[growling/ snarling]
(Mark) Oh...kay. Are you naked?
-Oh...kay. Are you naked?
It'd be much better if you were naked.
Don't ask me why.
You might be naked.
oooh-kay.
I'm just gonna be very cautious about this, to not alert you to my presence.
'Cause Christmas isn't anytime soon
hehehehehe....
OHHHH!!!
AGHH!!
OH! EW!
You like to cook!?
Is that what you're eating?!
Oh-kay.
-[Chainsaw buzzing]
(Mark) Oh Goo-ahahahah aw...
oh ho ho...
oh, boy
I think this whole playthrough I haven't been able to say anything clever.
All I've been doing is going
'AGH that's disgusting!!'
Hi.
Nice beard.
Or is that just the entrails of the fallen on your face?
AHHFUU-!
Why did I do that?!
(Frank) Don't you look at us. I love him.
(Mark) Phew! G-good, I'm not one to stop your love.
Did you microwave his head until his brain exploded?
Oh, God!
That is so gross!
Oh, that's so gross!
Why am I still looking at it?
Ech! Agh! Agh! Agh! Agh!
Do NOT follow me and chase me, dude.
If you do, I will be very forced to run away from you screaming like a little girl.
And I don't wanna do that to my lovely fans.
Actually, they'd probably love to see that.
Hello!?
Is anybody home in this bathroom?
Which is always a good thing in horror games.
Lots of hiding places for me to get-
-[slamming]
(Mark) Nothing! There's nothing!
Ah, it was nothing.
Probably nothing...
Morphogenic Engine up in my eyeballs.
It's nothing.
Just a whole lot of nothing.
Fun
Fun, fun
Fun, fun, fun!
(prisoner 1)... I think it's safe. Can you climb up?
(Mark) Uh-huh
(prisoner 2) I'm coming, Cooper. I just have to lock the... There.
(Mark) No.
(prisoner 2) I'm coming. Hold on.
(Mark) No!
(Mark) I don't know what you did
but I probably need to go that way so please don't.
"Unlock the handcuffs..."
Oh, good.
I gotta go back and find the key!
Good For Me!
All right, anyway.
This seems like a good place to stop this part.
I went on a little longer than I thought just because I was really into the story, but either way...
This.
This. Is.
This. Is. Awesome!
It's like... it's a shame because Outlast doesn't have custom stories, like Amnesia does.
So, you can only get these in, like, official doses from the creators, but that means it's always gonna be
a very cool experience!
So, this is a dead, set, awesome, "dedicated to Outlast" DLC here
And I can't wait to play more.
I can't wait to see what other surprises are in store for me.
So, anyway...
Thank you all so much for watching!
If you enjoyed this video leave a like to let me know.
Let me know what you think in the comments below.
And as always...
I will see you...
I will see you in the next video!
Buh-Bye!